human physiology doesn't adapt well to
space and things start failing the body
the balloons begin to leach out minerals
that it thinks it doesn't need in a
microgravity environment it's got to be
replaced we're learning about problems
in the eye and the vision your muscles
sort of atrophy your nose is congested
you feel like you've got a cold so the
physical challenge of getting to Mars is
going to be fun right you've been in a
zero-gravity environment for some eight
months which is like being in bed frame
months suddenly you'll have this frenzy
of fighting physics to slow down to land
on the surface your coordination your
musculature your cardiovascular system
your respiratory system all of that is
all of a sudden under a gravitational
load you actually have to keep working
hard such that when we land on a surface
like Mars you can recover quickly and
begin to work radiation is a problem
anywhere outside of a strong magnetic
field so if you're on earth you're fine
if you're in low-earth orbit like the
International Space Station is you're
still fine but if you're heading to Mars
now you've got a problem right now
there's two sources of radiation that
we're gonna have to deal with one of
them is called G CRS stands for galactic
cosmic rays there are tiny little
particles that are moving very very fast
like you know approaching the speed of
light kind of fast yeah they're kind of
radiation or solar radiation and they're
fast-moving particles but they're not
nearly so fast as the GCRs
the longer you spend exposed to that yet
the higher your cancer risk we are like
pre-programmed to be predisposed to hang
out with other humans so being very very
far away from civilization is scary to
us
loneliness of being uprooted not only
from your world but from everything
anyone who you're truly close to is
probably a terrible thing there are a
series of very dynamic events separated
by long periods of nothing happening
spacecraft is this monotonous gray and
tan I almost wondered why NASA just use
that kind of pukey beige color for
everything they've got to stay together
in a tiny spaceship for months and
months then hang out a tiny habitat for
months and months and so it's a form of
human sacrifice but not in the complaint
las' way but really in the service of
something much greater
you